hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the first the final match Hikaru
Nakamura vs. Daniel du Bois Vieux Carre
won the first game with the black pieces
and now dubov needs a win to get back
into the match so without further ado
let's check it out as a game 2 is also a
very interesting one so Nakamura opens
with E for like he did against Magnus
with E 5 933 but now these six the du
Bois goes for the Pierce defense sorry
for the Philidor defense we have d4 and
now he captures on d4 with knight
characters in out in 90 to f6 so this is
a fairly standard nice to see 3 and the
Bishop to e7 now preparing the castle
nakamura develops the Bishop to c4 which
is of course the way you want to develop
as deep into your opponent's position as
possible castles by do both and the
castles by Nakamura and now c6 preparing
some a5 and B 5 expansion on the Queen
side so rook to e1 at some point you
wanna play Bishop before try and get
this pawn to e5 and so on so a 5
preparing be 5 so nakamura stop set a
for taking care of b5 and now Knight to
a6 and there is one game in the database
for Queen to f3 was played but here
nakamura goes for Bishop to f4 and it is
already as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so dubov continues
with knife to c5 he needs to get this
night away from the edge of the board
and knights the b3 immediately
challenging that night with Knight back
to e6 now attacking Nakamura's Bishop
Bishop g3 and now g6 by dubov and here
Nakamura I take this opportunity to go a
5 so he does there's no you don't have
time for d5 or something like that since
there are too many pieces would be
hanging here so basically the choice is
between Knight e8 and captures and the
night that I ate looks ugly and it's not
only the that it looks ugly it is ugly
for example captures captures and now
after a trade here on e6 Bishop captures
captures Knight c5 is very strong here
attacking the bishop twice also there's
an attack on the b7 pawn and well Du
Bois just doesn't like his chances here
so instead duo goes D captures an 85 and
offers a
Queen trade Nakamura captures an e5 and
now Queen captures on d1 so the Queen's
are of the board and rook to d8 Luba
wants to trade off a pair of rooks and
knights to d4 now by Nakamura with a
double attack on the night here so nice
- eh either are shifting the night over
over let's say to g7 then to f5 but also
maybe Bishop to f6 will be an idea in
the future so nakamura trades here
Knight captures Bishop captures we have
characters characters and now a Knight
to e2 preparing to put the C pawn but
also you want to get your knight into
the game to attack the e6 pawn and now
the material is equal however do both
three point islands Nakamura to Papa a
two point islands and there's an
isolated es exponent that Nakamura will
try and make a target so Bishop f6 we
have captures and now before recapturing
root cap person D 1 we have rook
captures and Knight captures on f6
taking care of the d7 squares so there
aren't any real if it's possible f3
taking away efore and g4 from dubov and
now king f7 just getting the King into
the game with Knight to f4 by Nakamura
and E 5 now attacking the knight Knight
to d3 again attacking it and rook to e8
and here rook to e1 attacking that pawn
and now dubov has to decide how to how
to go about it do you go nice to d7 and
defend the pawn or do you try and trade
everything off with E 4 and this is what
the dubov goes however efore is not to
be the absolute best choice Knight to d7
although passive was a little bit better
but I feel free to pause the video here
and try to figure out why it's not the
best choice for for black well I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that this in
fact loses the pawn and for those of you
who just wanna enjoy the show it's nice
the c5 now the point is the b7 point is
under attack and then all everything
nicely connects just captures characters
captures and so on point is if you go
for ECAP force on f3 then you get a rope
capture Sonny 8 king captures and Knight
captures here and now the a 5 point will
fall let's say capture ciri are gonna
capture here King defense now King
captures here
and it's a 3 connected points on the
queenside against one okay it's due to
one on the King set for black here but
it's it's a pawn up and what white is a
much better here
so instead after night to c5 do bow goes
for B 5 but now Nakamura just picks up
the e4 pawn so Knight captures any for
tonight captures and of course the
immediate rook at present he for
Nakamura rise up upon so of course he
wants to he wants the trade rooks not do
both the clients and now a capture son
b5 with captures and King if to bring in
a King into the game du veau tries to
pick up some points but of course the
rook to e8 e to blocking rugby 1 and now
King to e3 we have kinked the e6 and now
c3 so nakamura wants all of his pawns to
be protected here rook the h1 and now g3
the rook is now guarding both the h-bond
ended the b-pawn we have king d v by dou
gov and f4 now so it's not much it's a
rockin game you're up upon but it is it
is something in the previous game
Nakamura was able to win a pawn and win
the game so what happens here
dubov goes for h5 and now King to d3
with a four by dubov and rook to f2 now
a preparing some f5 ideas then if
captures then recaptures with check you
get to pick up some points so rook to d1
with check and our King C to look back
to g1 and now finally f5 going forward
for this if you allow f6 then is just
lost so G captures an f5 and now rook
captures on a5 followed by King to c4
Nakamura now goes looked for check first
he wants to get the black King away from
such an active square so King c5 and now
look to h4 so now he defends this point
and he will only then capture here
without allowing the black King a lot of
activity so King to d5 and only now rook
captures on h5 with check King c4 and
now route back to h4 with the check King
c5 and now rook to d4 so I Nakamura
grabbed another pawn and now he has to
connect past bonds on the Kings side
rubgy to check now rook the d2 blocking
of course dubov cannot trade rook so
Luke g1 and now h4
camera gives up the g3 pond start
pushing his past H bond and a dubov of
course grabs it and now rook the h2 the
rook is behind the passport and now it's
not not gonna be easy to defend
so B for C capture skin characters and
an outcomes of course h5 with a3 do both
trades of the last the last remaining
pawn but first
rook to h4 with Czech and this is very
important
for example if if you just capture the
pawn be captures on a3 rook captures on
a3 then and this is this is a non
theoretical draw which are both the duo
in Nakamura know so instead first looked
the h4 width check King to c5 pushing
the King back and now b4 with check so
not allowing the trade to happen here
kink the b5 and only now rook to h6 so
now if you put the pawn the King can
still reach it it's not a problem
look the g2 with check King Tubby one
and now King the a4 trying to close in
and Nakamura asking and maybe maybe
force a draw by some checkmate
checkmating threats but h7 and now h8 is
already coming so rook the g1 check King
to see two rook the g2 check King to d3
and it was in this position that Daniel
Du Bois resigned the game and that means
that Nakamura is leading the match by 2
point margin which means that human
needs a draw from the next two games to
win the first match and here you resign
because there's not much to be done here
after one more check King c4 next move
you get a queen into the game and there
is nothing black can do about that
or even try and and prolong the game
somehow even if you go for this just the
Queen and the Queen exquisite so it's
not not a problem for for Nakamura so
like I said after this King to be three
move were resigned and another victory
for Hikaru Nakamura so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank shy grows out of a comment Gabriel
look a blush cottage and Richard Wagner
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video Sarah thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage
Lenore's abbey finals checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Monday